yeah welcome back and thanks for
sticking around and sometimes gonna give
the second talk on robots is stochastic
center yeah thanks for coming back I
guess I didn't scare you enough so we
left off with the following statement
that if you look at the SGD as a way to
solve the IT problem this you know that
the problem of minimizing a expected
loss then at the end of the day we're
going to be bouncing deterministically
the following objective and and and I
have written here so in fact let me give
a name to this objective or to this
process
and it's going to be called online
linear optimization online linear
optimization and it's it's you know
nothing fancy
so for T from one to n we predict or
choose you know the choose W hat T and
then observe in that notation nabla G
and that's it right so that's the that's
the process think of this as a game and
in fact we're going to be writing these
as games later I and the goal is to have
small one over n sum of w hat t minus w
star in fact for any n w let's say so
for any W in some set F we want the sub
optimality
Noblet T it could be less than something
and this something is called a regret
bound okay so that's token that's the
word that I'm going to use this as a
regret bound so how much we're how much
we regret or not regret not using not
knowing the optimal w right
now what what the feature of this online
in your optimization framework is that
we will require the statement to hold
for any sequence of a Noblet T that live
in some set ok so we can't let them be
completely arbitrary but if they live in
some set they're bounded in some dual
norm let's say then we want the
statement to hold for any sequence right
and that's essentially what what we're
proving and if you look at even you know
like numeric ski notes he always says
that these gradients can come from an
arbitrary field they don't have to be
necessarily gradients of some function
right this statement can be proved for
arbitrary sequence so just here's the
proof right it's two lines you write the
W hat T plus 1 minus W that's a
projection of course it's closer than
the unprojected version right then you
open up the square you get these terms
hopefully I did it correctly then you
rearranged that's the object you want
right that's the inner product that you
want you put it on the left side these
differences telescope when you add them
up over time and so you get the
statement then if you choose step size
optimally you would get the 1 over
square root of and rate times the
diameter of the of the set F times the
size of maximum size of the gradients
right so that's the kind of a trivial
result right ok so that gives you this 1
over square root of n and and and the
point here is that you know that's the
same result that we've got for the
empirical risk minimization except we
never had to go through uniform
convergence right and so the puzzle here
is did we avoid somehow uniform
convergence or is it hidden somewhere
and and and the answer is that there is
a depend of answer to that and that's
there is some uniform convergence and
the very fact that we were able to prove
convergence of gradient descent means
that there is a some exist the implies
existence of some strongly convex
function and that is related to uniform
convergence or for marking gales over so
that's it so that that's just for I
guess experts maybe I shouldn't go in
that direction so no we didn't we didn't
avoid completely the the Union from
deviations right it's just hidden in a
different place but they're not but
another question that's kind of the
suggest is you know is this possible is
it possible that we can actually get the
data dependent Rademacher Brown right
that that depends on the sequence of the
gradients right remember the sequence of
the gradients for the loss functions the
loss function is the absolute value of y
minus WX for our example and so the
gradient of that loss is proportional to
X T right so when I say empirical
Rademacher complexity it would be
essentially XT the nobbler would be XT
times some real value right it's
essentially the the empirical Rademacher
complex that we had from the from before
the answer to this is actually we don't
know okay i'm suggesting that we we know
but we actually don't know for the
online linear optimization where but
when this is true but there will be
another scenario that I will briefly
well that I will shortly describe in
which we do know that you know when this
is possible and in fact that scenario is
more interesting than this one yes
nathless yeah this would be very
surprising right because there is no
there is no distribution than you are
right
this is a statement completely
deterministic lines to prove right that
holds for all sequences so why would
this be the case right okay so as you
were saying it seems crazy to think that
you know statistical quantities such as
these empirical Rademacher complexity
would should govern regret of a
completely deterministic quantity that
holds for all sequences or is it so let
me give you an example where in fact we
know we know that it is true
so consider again the set F from which
the W's come equal to the set X from
which the covariates come that's the
Union Euclidean Bowl and converse is our
projected gradient descent and the only
thing that we're going to change is that
the step size is this adaptive step size
okay so it's 1 over square root of the
gradients that you've seen so far
then a variant of the two line prove
that I showed gives the following
inequality the following regret
inequality again for any sequence of
nablas the you know the the regret bound
can be written in terms of the Nablus
itself I think it's somewhere in
numerous key probably deterministic
deterministic they don't have to be
gradients of anything yes yes
okay this is easy to prove and if you
know Kinchin Kahane inequality it is an
upper but it is upper bounded by the
expected norm of the Rademacher averages
which is the right amount these are the
empirical Rademacher averages right so
there is one case I guess this is other
grad red maybe one of the versions of
other ground we do have a case where
there's a some completely deterministic
statement that holds for all sequences
of nablus right with that recurrence
update you get the empirical Rademacher
complexity any questions that seem
mysterious that that could be ever
possible if I'd let you said it in the
beginning right the expectation like if
you think about that with gaussians well
now this is just like I mean with it's
actually geometric it's not intimate
yeah exactly it's and it's perhaps mr.
can be taken out of this is if you think
of some dramatic quantities and of
course both behavior of random walks
you know behavior of martingales are
strongly related to the geometry and
geometry is related to optimization so
it's not crazy to think that you can
close the loop and talk about the and
it's also clear that empirical
Rademacher at least the expected
empirical Rademacher would be a no sorry
sorry
empirical Rademacher it would be a lower
bound on this online linear optimization
problem because if you just present coin
flip times the gradient sorry point foot
times the nabla then in expectation the
first term is zero obviously and you get
the well there should be an expectation
here over the Epsilon's and that's
exactly the empirical ran amok all right
so that's also a lower bound so up to a
constant this is for the l2 l2 geometry
that's the best you can do
[Music]
yes so the so the question is can we get
this random ocker upper bound for a
different geometry using your descent
and the answer is not really because
this if you know about you know black
spaces this is a it statement about code
type
and so you would lose here very badly in
terms of dimension and and other things
possibly even the rate if you want to
keep the dimension free result
but for experts okay but but of course
this you can get with mirror descent
right so there is adaptive version of a
mirror descent that gives this with a
with a appropriate norm as long as you
can find a strong a convex function
which means that the you have to smooth
the norm potentially okay all right so
let me step back what does the grand
goal the grand goal is we started with
iid data we looked at the matrix
prediction example it's a bad assumption
for a matrix completion we went ahead
with that assumption and saw that the
empirical random are averages is the
right bound for the performance of both
SGD and erm then we saw that in that
proof of SGD there is something hidden
there that's completely deterministic
and now the question is can we actually
get rid of the random X Y and say that
we're gonna have some result for all
pairs X Y right and that would be very
[Music]
interesting for the matrix conclusion
for instance if you have some kind of
robustness result right for individual
sequences of course it means that we'll
have to work much harder to do that so
what are we gonna do let me introduce
instead of a on line linear optimization
let me introduce a slightly different
setting which i think is more
interesting and and and kind of this
this setting is not itself interesting
it's it's only interesting as as a step
you know as a stepping stone to
something else right so here is the
setting will have a interaction that
less lasts for n rounds on each round we
observe some covariates XT we make a
prediction let's say it's bounded
between minus
one for the Y variable and then we
observe the actual the outcome right
this is going to be called online
supervised learning as opposed to online
linear optimization right slightly
different setting the goal is to have
small error relative to this F as before
except here we have our prediction - the
outcome as the loss right versus the
benchmark and we would like to have this
result for all sequences is this
possible well I didn't say what the
result is but we want upper bound this
for all sequences right we want to
develop a strategy such that our loss is
as good as the benchmark and hopefully
it's just enough to assume that Y's are
close to W times X G in you know most of
the time but no iid assumption right so
is that is that clear we want to get rid
of the iid assumption and get a result
for all sequences and the result will
only be interesting if our hunch is
correct that the Y's are explained by
linear function of the X's right so we
only want to do as well as the benchmark
and this was the case with statistical
learning as well right we had this
minimum over a linear predictors except
we have we have the iid assumption right
so why is this learning let me explain
well it is learning because you're
making out-of-sample predictions right
it's not just fitting the data it is
about prediction you're making a
prediction y hat T for this individual
before observing the label for that
individual right so let's think of
matrix completion right X's are the user
movie pair so at each round you observe
a user movie pair and you have to make a
prediction whether they will like that
movie or they will not like that movie
and I'm allowing kind of a mixed
strategy you can think of this as a the
mean of the
of a random variable okay and that's
that's what we're going to pay right yes
so if you do something like that but
sign you know sign of inner product of W
and XT yes so how much does that change
the problem a lot and it seems to bump
into like hardness of exactly yes so I
will you're jumping
one slide ahead of me so I'm correct
well if you put a sign here what will
happen and give me just a couple of
minutes and in particular what I would
like to do is to to see whether we can
get an empirical Rademacher complexity
this is a difficult goal and so I'm not
sure I'm actually gonna get to it but I
can give a pointer to a paper that at
least says you know under these
conditions this is possible I mean are
you an example the you know having YT
being a real valued number between minus
1 and 1 would actually help over us
minus ones why it would help it helps
algorithmically because we you know
that's a it becomes a nicer problem to
solve
and I'm doing here it for simplicity as
well but you can think of this as a kind
of the mean of the strategy right and
and so you think of log loss right a
logarithmic loss you you put down a
distribution and you pay minus log of
the probability that you put on the
outcome right it has the same feel
accepted sir you know absolute value of
the difference
so think of Y hat is the probability you
can pay from 0 to 2 1 right for putting
or 2 - ok so once again kind of going
back to black well this is going one
layer above with what what he was doing
in terms of introducing the covariance
which is the interesting part but again
we will have to work harder to to
realize the same result without the iid
assumption right that's the goal and let
me say that this connection between the
ability to get the results similar to
what you get in the iid setting or in
stochastic setting but for individual
sequences this connection has been
noticed by many people in the in in
different communities and this one is
from information theory have a classical
paper by marivan feather and Universal
prediction loosely speaking there is a
strong duality between the probabilistic
and deterministic setting where you
assume that data comes from some source
for them actually it's not necessarily
iid and the deterministic where you want
something for all sequences while in the
former you make a certain assumptions on
the data sequences that you are likely
to encounter but no limitation on the
class of prediction algorithms and the
latter is the way the other way around
so I just want to point out that you
know many times in the literature this
has been noted but there hasn't been
really a crisper understanding of why
this is happening
ok and now now back to a I'm course a
question do we always expect that
iid results will coincide with something
for individual sequences and the answer
is actually no so this is not something
that you should necessarily expect and
there there are examples where it's not
possible and and here's the example
where when the separation appears you
take the loss function to be the
indicator loss okay so think the pack
setting in the iid case if you take
thresholds
so these are just on the line X is a
real variable and this is a threshold
parameterize by theta that has VC
dimension 1 if you know what that is if
not all that means is that the empirical
risk minimization can still be possible
or still has the rate of convergence of
1 over square root of n right so you
still have this expected loss of the
empirical risk minimizer compared to the
best in hindsight is 1 over square root
of N and yet there is no way to get our
individual sequence result there is no
way there is no randomized or
deterministic method that will give you
the analog of the average number of
mistakes - the best given by some best
threshold better than the constant maybe
1/2 or 1 ID and remember of the constant
and and again there is a deeper
connection I can point to a paper with
Karthik's theater and martingale
extensions of application running case
theory and it is just a question of
martingale uniform convergence versus
iid uniform convergence and as soon as
you have a gap you will have a gap here
as well for linear the essentially no
gap so you would have to work very hard
to find a space where martingales
behaved differently from iid the
difficulty here is really in this
infinite precision of the of the
adversary that he can choose sequences
just around the threshold and in fact
what we showed is that if you the Midori
if you think of these sequences as being
generated by adversary if the hand of
the adversary trembles even within
exponentially small size you get back to
the iid kind of setting so it's really
kind of it's really this discontinuity
of the indicator loss that's
kind of a trouble but you might imagine
a higher dimension just got to get
through that possibly yes the results
are rather limited on kind of
characterizing classes of functions
beyond just saying that uniform
convergence happens but again so I just
want to maybe spend two minutes that
this is a has deeper connections to
perceptron for those of you who don't
know what perceptron is you know this is
the beginning of machine learning
that's also in 57-59 Rosenblatt
introduced the perceptron which is you
know you have a sequence x1 y1 and so
forth right x and y n and maybe longer
and the problem is like this for T from
1 to N you observe XT you predict Y hat
T in plus minus 1 and then you observe
the YT in plus minus 1 and if there is a
mistake you actually update so these
predictions are made by not arbitrarily
but in a proper manner they were made by
w hat t is a sign WT let's say hat x xt
so you you make predictions according to
your current a hyperplane and then you
update the hyperplane so if there is a
mistake then you correct your hyperplane
T plus 1 is w hat T plus y t
and and there is no step size here
because you can rescale everything the
data are separable and so there is a
reason why you don't need the step size
here or it shouldn't change anything
so then Nabokov proved that the if data
are separable separable with a margin
so what is margin there exists a W star
such that Y I times W X I is larger than
gamma and the nor W star and the norm of
W star is one you have to rescale
renormalize you know something
so you even if there exists a unit
direction that separates the data by
gamma then the number of mistakes number
of Corrections is at most
the radius of the data squared to the
radius of the axis divided by gamma
squared that's the perceptron mistake
bound and this was essentially the the
beginning of machine learning right gave
rise to this what was what what pink was
referring to at least in in the Soviet
Union as the the study of online both
methods that would produce learning
pattern recognition machines
and and this is a paper from 68 just
before vaping considered when incus came
up with their sour shell ulema
I guess smoking shell rank is Sarah
[ __ ] Lima if you know what what it is
so this is for the experts and then they
have this kind of an interesting
paragraph they say either you can you
know get this result that does not
depend on the dimension of the space and
then convert it into the IIT result
right this holds for all sequences then
you say oh but my sequences were iid and
therefore you can get a rate of
convergence for the expected loss in
terms of something that depends on the
margin but not on the dimension of the
data or you can go through the VCA type
of analysis where you get the VC
dimension in there and that's dimension
of the space so there is a clearly two
different ways of getting the result and
they were wondering why there are two
different ways of getting the result and
now we know that because of the previous
slide for thresholds it's not possible
to do something for all sequences you
can only get it for sequences that are
separable and the result that you get is
at least and that statement is in terms
of the margin but for iid data you can
get a result for all distributions and
that just depends on the dimension of
the space right so there are two ways of
gaining doing it and and they they're
different right so that's all I want to
say
so why is this online linear
optimization interesting well because if
you can solve the online linear
optimization then it you can use it for
the online supervised learning problem
that I outlined before right online
supervised learning again is you observe
the the X the covariate you make a
prediction and then you observe the
outcome and how do you do it you do it
in the proper what's called the proper
learning way is it you update the
gradients as a projective gradient but
then you the gradient that you feed them
to the online linear optimization is the
gradient of the loss function right so
if you can solve this then you can solve
online supervised learning problem right
so that's hopefully clear just by
convexity however this is not
necessarily the best idea why so first
of all this is a proper learning method
in the sense that you actually look at
the you work with the space of w's and
you you you have a solution that's
consistent or sorry you have a solution
that's within the class of models where
is the online supervised learning
framework here just asks for a number to
predict the number and that's
potentially a much simpler optimization
problem and in fact it can circumvent
certain hardness results if you look at
it this way rather than online linear
optimization way okay okay so what you
know if you were lost in the last couple
of slides let me bring you back I'm
going to give you a sense of how online
supervised learning and online linear
optimization can be solved through
dynamic programming and and hopefully
this will give you a sense of why
something can hold for arbitrary
sequences right for all sequences why
you can get a result that does not
depend on the iid nature of the data and
this is through the dynamic programming
so to make it very simple I'm gonna
throw away the excess we're in a setting
where you make a prediction y hat T in
the real line and then you observe a
binary outcome so I'm simplifying it
even more because I'm not restricting
your prediction to be in the plus minus
one interval just to make the recursion
simple okay now one way to write the
optimization problem is that I want to
minimize over the space of strategies
prediction strategies such that for any
sequence I have some prediction
performance right all you can say all
right you know you can you can you can
write any problem in this way right so
whenever you want to develop a method
that will work for this class of
problems you can always write in a
minimum over algorithms maqsuum /
problems the performance of the
algorithm on the project so you haven't
done anything but it turns out that
because it's a sequential prediction
problem it actually decomposes into a
bunch of smaller dynamic programming
steps and that's key so something that
looks horrible when you write it that
like that becomes actually simple as
when you consider its stage wise okay
the particular form that we will
consider is average of the losses right
so think of this as why I had T minus YT
for instance - well something about the
sum function of the sequence and I'm
doing it purely for syntactic for
notational purposes it can be any in in
fact it can be any fee function but you
know you think of this fee function it's
the minimum over some vector of the loss
of that vector for this or the best
vector for that sequence okay
does that make sense so this is the
benchmark that we wanted
we'll compare against right I remember
the online go back right this is the
benchmark so I'm gonna call this feat
what's important is that this part does
not depend on our decisions on our
predictions that's key that's key to
solving this dynamic program efficiently
okay I'm gonna add some constant C
that's gonna be important later so now
it's just some constant what I want to
say is that if we prove that this is
upper bounded by zero this min Max upper
bounded by zero then we've got the
individual sequence prediction result
right okay then maybe it's not obvious
so let me let me make sure that everyone
understands this yes question
what nothing to do with the y-hat tease
because the proof will go will go
through for any fee and it's it's just
easier to to write it in terms of fee
but if you want think of fears being
equal to that if you would like this so
think think think this yeah yeah right
exactly right right so the question is
you know why is it the why do we write
general fee just for notation purposes
it's going to be simpler right but the
proof will work for any fee but you can
think of this particular fee I think
something that's actually non-trivial I
guess is is I want to make sure that
everyone understands this is if we can
ensure that this is upper bounded by 0
then we have this result that we want
but for all sequences there are no X's
because I threw them out right so fro
there's just the Y sequence right the
number of mistakes is upper bounded by
this fee function in fact let me go back
to the black hole example right we were
predicting a sequence it was a zero one
sequence doesn't matter and we would
like to do as well as the proportion of
ones and proportion of minus one or
proportion of ones and zeroes the
maximum of that right or in terms of
mistakes we want to do not worse than
the number of the minimum of the number
of ones and number of minus ones windows
so that you can write in fact as this
minimum over two different F's one is
just all zeros or I guess it's a binary
prediction all minus ones and the other
vector is all ones and that will exactly
give you the objective that you're
trying to optimize in that Blackwell
example that we started with right this
is easy to easy enough to see that
if we can solve it it will give the
solution to the black wall a problem yes
you're first that's actually good point
so when we write it like this we write
it over a sequence the sequence can be
adaptive to our moves right and and so
that that's called adaptive other words
I want to sweep it under the rug for a
moment and just say that nothing will
change the Y hat here seems like a good
ticket arbitrary Y hats are functions
here there are functions from the past
it's a strategy right so it's a minimum
over strategies right but but also you
can say the same thing about the
adversary and now I realize this is bad
notation right so I'm thinking this of
you know you can think of this as
sequence or strategy for the adversary
and and this is definitely strategy so
this is definitely not the minimum over
predict yeah sorry exactly right right
exactly
average loss is smaller than the fee
that's but it's a multi-stage game right
so we'll have to roll back do we need to
pick like exactly we create can be think
of like v8 function yeah so you can you
can think everything will be much harder
right so I'm actually just for the
illustration purposes let me actually
pick this loss right it's it's you might
say it's not natural I just want to show
why Rademacher appears right button and
this will be very simple there regrets
yes so you can consider with something
other yeah you can replace it with
something other than just average of the
losses yes so if you think about so
there's some
you can do that as well or you can
consider cat what's called calibration
where you want to predict the weather
and and and you want to say that you
know after a hundred days my frequency
of predicting rain whenever I predict a
20% rain like on the weather calm in
fact the empirical frequency was twenty
close to twenty percent so that's a call
to calibrated forecaster and that you
can also write in this notation so
that's gonna be much more complicated I
had - before and then I switch to two
plus just to illustration purposes so
think of this as a it doesn't matter you
can just put a minus there and it just
change the signs later yep okay so
that's the objective and in all these
problems what you do is you do the last
step and once you do the last step it
hopefully gives you an idea of how to go
back right how to roll back so what do
you do at the last step the y1 through Y
2 y n minus ones are fixed these are
fixed numbers you've observed them
you've you had your chance to predict
them you did something and they're fixed
what can you do now so the only thing is
your remains to choose the y hat n right
and if these were an indicator loss you
would choose a mixed strategy but
because it's a linear loss you can show
that it's enough to have a deterministic
choice okay so now you do have a minimum
a min max right so you have to choose a
prediction such that for any outcome you
control loss - the this fee function
right
is it clear that this is the objective
that you need to solve it the last step
right everyone there's nothing else you
can do right that's that's the one you
need to solve okay but it's trivial to
solve it it has a closed-form solution
this is a max so plug in plus one here
and here and plug in minus one here and
here and now you have a minimum of one
with positive slope and one with a
negative slope the minimum is attained
at the intersection of these two lines
and you don't have to worry because I
said over R you don't have to worry
about projecting back to you know a
proper interval and so you just get the
closed form strategy when you plug this
back in what is the value that you get
of this whole objective well you get
minus half of the fee with the plus one
and half of the people the minus one oh
that's just the expectation of our over
a random walk around and variable right
so it's somehow it appears magically
just because you have solved the the the
the saddle point problem right and and
now you roll back so it's clear that
when you do you know you now you think
of this as the fee function the new fee
function you put it back in solve it an
N minus one and one by one these guys
are going to turn into the rather macro
random variables and so at the end of
the day you will just get the expected
value of the fee function so visually
what's happening is that you have this
recursion right you you solve this
problem once you've solved it you call
this minus V and now you solve the
previous one and and so forth right so
as long as you can do that in a closed
form way you cannot do it numerically
because you that would blow up the kind
of the state space right but if you just
the do it in terms of the kind of
functional form closed form then you're
done come all the way to there
I it will just second let me show I just
want to show that what we're solving is
actually what what we want to solve and
right push these guys into the mean
maxes right they're all out here but you
can push in to aggregate them together
in one place and so that's gonna be this
right and though so you can write min
max min max min max min Max Mirnyi so
it's this horrible thing but it
decomposes to much simpler optimization
problems and we have this notation where
whenever we have things repeated like
min Max or sometimes it's min max
expectation or in expectation max we
just have this notation to say that it's
repeated this operator is repeated over
time right you can think of this as a
function of many variables and now there
are the operators like min max our
expectation that are being applied
sequentially to this to the subjective
to bring into a different game right
there so you can think of this as
transitioning from one game to another
game and that's exactly the meaning of
our algorithms max over sequences which
hides a lot right so when you write it
as min max well there is no way to
optimize it but when you unroll it in
this notation that it is solvable okay
so the conclusion remember I said that
if we can show that this min Max is less
than zero then there exists a strategy
right now we showed that the the whole
thing is going to be upper bounded by
minus expected fee so as long as that
minus expected fee is a is low is upper
bounded by zero we're done that's
equivalent to just checking if they
expected views above zero right that's
the that's the only thing it to check so
the conclusion is that if you can check
this then there is an online algorithm
that will obtain that
is the statement clear I remember at
this point at this point I said that if
we can show that this whole thing min
max is upper bounded by zero then we
have this result and what we've proved
is that this is upper bounded not by
zero but by the - expect upper bounded
by - expected fee under the random coin
flips and so as long as the - expected
fee is upper bounded by zero
we have the result
okay let's take our favorite function
which is the benchmark it's the minimum
over vectors of the linear as a linear
loss or you can put minuses again you
can put minuses everything will will
work out exactly the same way so what is
this constant C M right it's needed why
is it needed because they expected
minimum when when Y's are Epsilon's is
less than zero
it's not more than zero so when you take
the expected minimum of of this it's
clear that expected minimum is going to
be small it's going to be upper bounded
by minimum of the expectation and that's
zero
so clearly we need to correct it so how
much do we correct it well it's a closed
form hey it's a rather marker right the
Rademacher averages just fall out
so it seems like it's happening for
completely different reasons right it
seems that it's happening for reasons
that are connected to the Optima what is
the optimal strategy for the adversary
maybe right this min max is solved at
the at the coin flip right
okay so the point here is that yes there
is an online algorithm and you can now
recover it go back and recover it from
the solution right so the way that we
solve this dynamic program that
guarantees what if this was a cave Aled
you would get like a vector-valued
random occur so there's a generalization
to it like a vector-valued random walk
around but this is the simplest possible
yes
okay so where can we go from here in the
next ten minutes so there are two
possibilities one is to go after this
problem and show you how things like
exponential weights which some of you
maybe have seen and the gradient descent
dual averaging arise as in fact
approximate dynamic programming
solutions or to put the covariance back
into the picture and try to solve the
online supervised learning problem which
i think is more interesting but I would
actually go with the first one because
it's easier to explain so let me in the
remaining twelve minutes show you some
of the results okay so what we've shown
is that for this bit prediction with
strange loss again just for simplicity
we get the right macro complexity now
let's go to the world of of online in
ear optimization and see what what's the
regret here what is the upper bound here
right
and let me just do the first step with F
being the Union ball a unit l2 ball
because again the comparator can be
written in this form right so this is
the few function now except it's a few
function of vectors not of bits right we
go from predicting bits to predicting
vectors ok so this is the last step of
that problem that you want to solve
it's a min/max product inner product and
the Euclidean norm of the sum so you
know we can solve it numerically but to
be able to show some interesting
statement you need a closed form right
so how do we how do we get a closed form
and there are a number of ways
essentially you need to relax this
problem you need to replace this
comparator the speed by some upper bound
and if we do that you get you know
hopefully not too bad of a relaxation
right so you need something that's close
to the norm so how do you get something
close to the norm well the first kind of
trivial thing to do is to put the square
and take a square root right and and and
and and take take the last guy out and
then kill the the quadratic part right
so what was the problem here this was
not a nice problem you you put square
and square root you would have the norm
of the nabla and squared and that would
be an ugly optimization problem but if
if you know that they're bounded by if
they're in the Union Bowl just replace
it by one it turns out that this already
gives you a closed form solution and
it's essentially some version of dual
averaging right it has a closed form
solution exact min max is of this form
so it is a right of type like this so
the intermediate steps
you take the average of the gradients of
the Nablus they don't have to be
gradients right of some function and
have a this step size so the only
difference is that the step size is kind
of strange right it has the data that
you've seen so far
you take the squared norm of the sum and
then a data independent part right but
this is exact solution for that
relaxation and there are many other
relaxations that you can try in
particular it guarantees that the bound
is 1 over square root of n actually
maybe there is some other constant there
okay so is that yes not yet because
other grad doesn't have this n - all
right so the reason it appears is
because we have fixed a horizon and and
for if we're sitting at time T we got
rid of this future right we can't have
the anomalous for the future but this
way of proof requires you to replace
them by something that's right
okay is it square let's do exponential
how many people know the exponential
weights algorithm or the multiplicative
the weighted majority oh get so many so
let me show you that again this is a
just a relaxation for that we have to go
to the different geometry right so
multiplicative weights is for
distributions that suggests the l1
geometry and if we take the primal dual
approach with the balls it's it's a
either l1 o infinity setup or simplex
and L infinity setup right so you can
you know roughly up to a constant these
are the same so what do we do for the
last step for the last step you minimize
over distributions maximum over L
infinity bounded vectors linear part
again plus the maximum right of all the
data that that's the last step
again intractable what do we do relax it
and and the natural ways to use a soft
max and that's what gives the
exponential ways the multiplicative ways
right so for in fact if you're free to
choose eight that's an equality right
its infimum rate that would be equality
so the or 8a is the step size that you
choose you can choose it later or you
can choose it adaptively as you go but
this is the this is the relaxation and
let's call it ZN right to remind you of
the log partition function
okay so you can write the inner product
just to match the the notation is a 1
over a to log X okay of course we
haven't changed anything right that's
equality and okay if you if you stir
enough at it you'll see that yeah you
can write Z n in terms of the expected J
from the exponential weights
distribution right the one that puts the
past gradients exponentiate them for
each coordinate okay now if you plug
this back in into that optimization
problem it's it's it's it becomes clear
that if you will get this recursion
going if you choose exactly that
exponential weight distribution it is
not the min/max strategy I believe for
that relaxation it's a choice but but
that's you know that allows the
recursion to go through and so you would
get the exponential weights algorithm
and here again the drum the bound that
you would get as log Z over and sort of
log the over and
yes we can get random technique
next so what other the question was
whether we can get other algorithms out
of this like randomized algorithms and
there are plenty of algorithms that
we've gotten out of this way of thinking
one thing you can do is to relax with
some LP norm for the experts and that
would lead to these polynomial
algorithms but another way another one
which is interesting is the is a
randomization where you take you add a
random vector here which is zero mean
and by Ensign inequality it's upper
bounded by expected max right so if
expectations were here you would get
have a zero as when you pull expectation
out it's a lower bound so that's in a
relaxation and now you can see that with
pretty much simple algebra that this
gives the randomized method which is
follow the perturb leader for those who
know the literature this is due to Kauai
and Impala 2005 roughly but actually has
a history of going back to to Hanon in
the in the 50s under the name of
fictitious smooth fictitious play where
you look at the current performance of
every expert and then you add noise to
them and then pick the best so that
smooths the the choices
I think this is going to be my final
slide I talked so far about the online
linear optimization and I I guess let me
go back
this expert bound is an upper bound on
Rademacher complexity
it's still unclear whether we can get
the actual rhythm of our complexities
upper bound or we can only get the upper
bound on the right amount of complexity
but when we go to the online supervised
learning setting with linear functions
then we have a characterization of when
we can get the desired bound and again
this is a result that holds for all
sequences does not require the iid
assumption and it's essentially the best
you can do even in the IAD case right
now it's for all sequences this is again
attractive for problems like networks
the matrix completion problem where
there is some interaction with the user
and so you just cannot assume that what
do you observe our iid data right so
anytime you have some kind of
interaction with a user in these online
problems it just concrete it as iid
right and so the hope is that if we can
get these results they will be more
robust to the behavior of the users and
let's say Netflix prediction and and and
do not rely on the iid assumption now
I'm not gonna go into the details it
turns out that there is another
geometric property of the space that Ben
was talking about in addition to strong
convexity or existence of a strongly
convex function there is another
function that turns out that has been
studied very much in a great extent in
in probability theory especially by
Burkholder it's called a special
Burkholder function and if we have
access to this function then we have an
efficient method for attaining this
bound and it's we still do not know
whether how to construct this function
for the spectral norm so I had maybe I
build up the expectation in other that
the I build up the expectation that the
there will be a result for matrix
completion that for all sequences gives
you an empirical
rather marker complexity and it is true
so we know that it it's possible but we
don't know what the efficient algorithm
is because we don't know how to
construct this function and and I think
it's a great kind of area now to explore
and come up with these Burkholder
functions that we do give rise to
efficient methods that give you
essentially what is the best possible
for all sequences right so we know we
know you just need to evaluate the
borrower hold our function it's okay I
can show you it just has to have this
property it has to dominate the
difference of special norms possibly to
some power if you want and it has to be
diagonally concave so this map it has to
be concave for the spectral norm that it
exists we know it exists yes let me not
leave that slide on because it looks
scary so we know this is possible pretty
much any problem that you care about
this will be possible for efficient
methods the game is on so we have a
bunch of results but not I should say
this is work with Karthik's veteran and
Dylan Foster any questions
Thanks
[Applause]
so the question is how hard is it to
compute the actual Rademacher complexity
for the linear case when you have a norm
it's it's easier so it's average over
random coin flips of a norm of a random
walk right it concentrates with respect
to the coin flip so you can get
approximate results you have a
concentration result right yeah more
generally if you can do empirical risk
minimization as a block box I think you
can evaluate the empirical evaluate
Rademacher complexity beyond that I
depends on what kind of access you have
to the function class right if you have
so no really thought you should report
for adaptive either no actually the way
that we the way that we wrote down the
game was actually for adaptive right
because you this choice can be made
based on everything so far yeah I think
well I I messed up the notation on on
this slide because here I meant this is
a strategy
okay that's
[Music]
[Applause]